okay let's get to hey treat male if
you've never heard of hatred mail before
when I say hatred mail this is what I
mean it's like a mandatory transvaginal
ultrasound for your mind Patriot Man
written by Patriots who hate David
Pakman because America and because
freedom
this week's hatred mail combines both
tried and true elements of hatred mail
namely anti-semitism against me as it
combines that with the sort of a timely
and topical nature of anti immigrant
fear and hatred let's take a listen to
this week's hey treat male do poor David
he is a Jew Mexican David you know
better than to pretend Jews are zweites
as of spanish-speaking Jew David cannot
understand an upper middle class white
man's plight beta male soy boy Chuck
god bless Trump you queerbait beta males
do not win David I'll make sure of it
for people who aren't reading the
transcript when you hear the high reverb
used on my name that's because it's
within triple parentheses which is the
sort of internet flagging of
anti-semitism by white supremacists they
will put Jewish people's names within
triple parenthesis and actually I forgot
homophobia also homophobia is is often
it's so common that there's homophobia
in these that it almost slipped past me
when I initially reviewed it right and
if you're gonna be offensive xenophobic
racist what have you at least get the
country of origin right Yeah right
you're not Mexican a lot of people
though seem to think that I am I
actually had a crazy conversation once
with someone where I said I'm from
Argentina I my native language is
Spanish I'm an immigrant from from
Argentina they said wait you're Mexican
is it no who said anything about Mexican
I'm from Argentina yeah a lot of
confusion they don't seem to understand
that you're also a citizen of the United
States that's correct
can't really be deported in that
remember I am a citizen thanks for the
reminder pad sometimes people forget
okay say fu to the hey tree 'it's with a
double middle finger like Maradona at
yesterday's Argentina game and use the
coupon code hey tree at 40 when you sign
up for a membership at join pakman.com